my parents are both alive my parents are  your parents alive how old are your  parents  76 74. and where do they live washington  dc how often do you see them like twice  a year okay so  most people be like okay you know i have  let's say your parents live till 80 so  they have five more years okay let's  just say roughly  you would say i have five more years of  my parents but i would say no  you have 10 more times with your parents  if you see them twice a year  you see them twice a year times five you  have 10 more times to see them when you  start thinking of things like that  your first reaction is i want to go see  my parents  at least that's mine so you change the  way you approach it i'm like i'm going  to go see my parents  every other month you know i'm going to  make it a priority